a lot of fans were thinking maybe we
would get some sort of a
surprise moment either an adoption or or
we find out that rosemary's pregnant but
instead you know she's developing in
other ways and she's really forging
her career path forward so i'm curious
was it ever a discussion in season eight
to introduce a child
yes absolutely yes it's been a constant
conversation
we haven't dropped the ball the fans
need to know that pascal and i
are definitely championing that we are
not dropping the ball we're being
tenacious
and we're trying to make that happen but
we'll see where it ends up
we're doing our best is there any reason
that you can maybe share or shed light
on
about why that storyline took a little
bit of a back seat
i think if there is any reason i think
it's logistics
we have one set of twins on the show and
it is challenging working with little
ones
and obviously covet hit this year and so
that made it more challenging to having
other kids come in and out and these are
all things that have to be brought into
the into the conversation
and whether you like it or not you get
gold from twins
but it does slow production down but
creatively speaking i don't think it's
ever been
an impediment i think that everybody
does want
this to happen it's just a matter of how
and when and now that that triangle is
out of the way and that's taken some of
the weight out of that
maybe this is a good logical place to go
next we had this similar conversation
last year around this time and you're a
house divided
she wants a movie i want to win rosemary
pregnant
lee and rosemary with the two kind of
quirky characters that they are to go
through that together
it's just as a gold mine of fun to be
had
but i understand the pull towards
adopting because obviously in real life
everybody needs a home
i think it would be hilarious to see
rosemary pregnant
i think if i were to line up all the
women in hope valley
and go who would i like to see play out
pregnancy
i would pick rosemary and not just
because i get to play her but because i
actually think it would be
so hilarious to see pregnancy because
you get to play her we all
know that's this no i believe pascal i
believe pascal i think
rosemary doing pregnancy you know she'd
be at dotties
dripping in in beads and making it the
most chic pregnancy moment possible
that's right that's right so i i think
that i can see the comedy in that very
easily
but i mean our show has also always been
about hope
and what's more hopeful than a child
finding a home i
am leaning one way more than the other
but i don't want to say which way
because
honestly it might be neither like i'm
not in control of this
storyline so we'll we'll see there is a
theory
that a lot of fans would love if
rosemary
and elizabeth were possibly pregnant
or expecting babies at the same time
what is your reaction to that pascal i
think our producers and writers
would have a nightmare i think their
heads would literally
explode not being happy
with that i think they would go this is
a logistical
production nightmare please no
we can't do that i think it's the
logistics of now suddenly
we've got three sets of twins that we're
trying to
schedule around their naps we're trying
to schedule around their temper tantrums
what are we saying
around your temper tantrums and that's
one spot that's already taken up
so yeah we don't have room for three
more divas okay
[Music]
the season eight finale elizabeth and
lucas
kissing passionately on the bridge
pascal
let's go to you first what was your
reaction
loved it loved it i mean during this
season honestly for a big part of it
when they were
writing the season it was still a
question mark who she was going to end
up with for a while
and all i said was the whole way along i
said
whenever the time comes for elizabeth to
actually
choose her man choose who she's meant to
be with
i said it needs to feel passionate
and i think they succeeded so you are
taking credit for it
yeah so i'm taking credit for it yeah
yeah fair enough i was like it needs to
feel
like cathartic like this huge
overwhelming
like overflow of emotion kevin the
resolution to this big love triangle
what was your reaction
about time uh
time i think that moment on the bridge
that you're talking about is a great way
to start it because it's like a notebook
kind of moment like
big time passion big rain big wet
kissing hair all that stuff it's very
it's a great place to start
the new journey and how we move forward
from there for that
little for that love triangle thank you
for waiting for me
we're all team elizabeth here seeing
that she followed her heart and went
with her gut instinct and and chose
to start a new journey with lucas what
do you make of
that i think it's a beautiful thing and
quite honestly
i actually think kevin mcgarry stated it
best
i saw an interview i think it might have
been with you actually
one of the suitors pushes her to be
better
and one of the suitors needs her to
help him be better at the core of it it
needs to be what can you give
like what are you giving to the other
person not what are you taking
and uh and so in that sense i feel like
lucas is the right person kevin how do
you feel about that
sorry i think you're cutting out here
[Laughter]
i thought it was a show about a lady in
a mountain
and i still think it's a show about a
lady and a mountie
who then moved on and now i think it was
the right choice for the story i think
for the show
um and i really think that now
we can explore an entirely different
chapter
pascal i want to talk to you about a big
moment in the rosemary storyline this
season
she taps into her creative instincts she
realizes her passion
and she starts the newspaper the valley
voice
i am the editor-in-chief
of
[Music]
the valley voice what do you make of
rosemary's latest endeavor
i think it's really exciting because i
think it utilizes a lot of rosemary's
skills but also
her maturity as a human being from where
she was in
season one and two um
which was a little bit flighty
i think she's just got more substance
now i think there's more
grounding to her as a character and so
she's ready and
able to take on a bigger project
like this and so i think that that's
exciting and i think
you know trying to juggle it all on her
own i think that that's a
huge endeavor and could lead to many
interesting storylines of
her trying to build this business
on it on her own kevin super
exciting kind of on a similar note we
really got to see
lee as well figure out what am i
passionate about
and in the season eight finale he says
i'm gonna run for mayor
you're gonna run for mayor no i'm gonna
run for me
how did you know that i got a nose for
news mr colter
what can you tell me about that in this
next era of lee's professional career
he just he's that kind of guy you come
to him in a crazy situation and he's
always calm he's always balanced he's
always equitable and fair and decent
and i think subconsciously
people have come to him over the years
either to be friends
or to be as a confidant or to you know
offer
or attain advice from and i think it
just sort of
culminated in the in the idea that he
likes
being that voice when they propose this
to me that they were talking of thinking
about
me running for mayor i thought
what a great what a great option so when
we're trying to to explore
where he wants to go and why he feels
like he's just
supplying the wood that other people use
to build things he wants to build
something and i think that that's a lot
of fun i'm all for it i don't know where
it'll go i don't know if he's going to
end up mayor
but i i certainly along for the ride
well i can't even begin to think of how
fabulous
rosemary would be walking around town as
the first lady
of hogue valley it would be pretty cool
you know it's funny kevin you said lee
sells
wood to people and they build things a
lot of fans on twitter are wondering
when the heck is lee gonna use some of
that wood to to make
rosemary the theater that she so richly
deserves
oh man we've been talking about that for
years too we make it's a side joke
between pascal and i
we get to the season opener and we're
like yeah so
i guess we'll be building that theater
this year knowing full well
there it's a very complicated thing but
i do think to tie that off a little bit
and i think the fans would love if they
go see a play at some point and
we could use the interior of an older
theater somewhere i think it would be
super exciting to do that pascal does
this feel overdue
yes it does i've always thought we
should surprise rosemary with
kind of almost an outdoor theater
because that
is fairly cheap and simple to build but
we could have occasional story lines
that utilize it
which i think would be really cool ah
patel that's brilliant mr tinker if you
are watching
this we would love you in amphitheater
outdoors please a place where rosemary
can finally put on the razzle dazzle
that we've all been wanting to see well
hopefully he's not watching this and
he's busy writing something
i have to congratulate the both of you
the good news we're getting more when
calls the heart
season nine it's happening what is your
reaction
super excited so thrilled so thrilled i
we love doing this show we really love
it
and uh to continue
doing what we love with the people that
we love
is just such a gift i i just kevin and i
i think everybody but i will speak
i'll speak for you for sure you always
do
this is something unique and so so
special and
the two of us do not take that for
granted we always throw a hypothetical
out
and we're always at the beginning of the
season it's like okay how long would you
stay around if you kept going how long
would you stick around and we're both
every time it's as long as it goes
as long as it goes i don't think i've
ever come across fans like
the ones for our show the hardys in
particular because
without them there is no show this is
this doesn't work
so every time they say yes we're gonna
do another season
i feel lucky like i just feel lucky
that is so nice to hear and you know i
when we spoke the three of us last year
around this time
i like to think that that conversation
might have had a little something to do
with the fact that you got extra
episodes
the fan base is so loyal and so good and
such a positive fan base
that i i don't want to disrespect them
or
mess with them and make them wait for
such a long period of time i don't want
to lose them
i really think that there's some
discussion to be had here on this one
you did it it really is a testament to
you guys and
you know coupled with the with the magic
of the hearties
and um and i truly just cannot wait to
see
what you guys continue to deliver so
with that
i'm curious what does season nine of
when calls the heart look like
for the cultures i hope there's a family
i want to see the cultures
as at least the threesome okay
whoa back back it up there this is this
is pg
there kevin but i don't mean it that way
only you would think of it that way
i'm the only guy here that thinks pg it
was an interesting choice of words but i
think it was a very
interesting choice okay let me see okay
i want to see the cultures
as a family yes i think
i mean i think that i would love the
fans to know that kevin and i are
championing that
as much as all of them are lee becoming
mayor rosemary's starting a newspaper
you keep forwarding that storyline and
then you throw in
a little gem like a baby and you got
something cool so aside from obviously
you want to see a child in the picture
is there anything else that you really
want to see them
explore in the season to come well
i'm gonna say this instead i love
working with this one
she's one of my best friends we don't
say that to each other very often
so i'm happy wherever this goes as long
as we get to keep doing this together
pascal what do you say to that i'm sorry
i missed that
i knew she was gonna say that
kevin and i we just work we work off
camera we work on
camera it's we've got such a short hand
and you can't plan for that
that chemistry that that it's intangible
and it just works
and that's just such a deep-rooted trust
in our relationship
and uh it's magic it's magic
you